um
if you allow a negative energy state to
propagate then people there's a big
worry because you can you know um those
degrees of things are usually called
ghosts
right when you have negative energy at
states that are propagated so it goes
usually is something that will have it
you have a negative kinetic energy so
um you know
whenever so Paul The Rock actually you
know um you know you know and and
stuckleberg and Feynman actually right
they saw these negative energy states in
the Klein Gordon equation of quantum
field Theory and the way around that was
to reinterpret having an eventually
State as an anti-particle moving
backwards in time right so you enter you
you said Okay I accept that those things
are but it's real but what I read what
that negative energy State really is a
positive energy state right that's an
anti-particle moving backwards in time
right so
um that's one way out of it you
reinterpret it another way out of it is
you you know you identify you can
identify if if it's a fermion right it
does you you do occupy these negative
energy states like the rock C right and
then the Exclusion Principle you know
will prevent you know the sea from
collapsing yes yes yes okay so
um but you do have to confront with your
theory why you would have this negative
Advantage you say that's bounded from
below and my the ideas that I work on
with my you know my students and
colleagues um was that what contributes
our negative energy state is a bound
state of fermions
right and so bound States
and if it's fermionic right
could could be in that you know so in
quantum mechanics you know bound states
are negative energy states so you know
the right right the the the
um the board you know the energy
um the ground the ground state energy of
um of um of hydrogen is minus 13.6
electron volts there's a minus sign
there right so the negative energy
states do exist in quantum mechanics and
those states are the bound States so
bound states are negative energy states
right so that's kind of the game we
played and so we're able to get a Bounce
by having fermionic bound States
actually like a Cooper pair
um but then you run into other problems
if you do that because then you have to
look you know if you do that you have
you can study fluctuations and in
cosmology we're not only interested in
just the homogeneous you know um average
expansion rate but we need to consider
fluctuations to talk about structure and
so you can ask if you turn on
fluctuations with these negative energy
states cause runaway Solutions and
that's an open-ended problem
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy